there's a spectrum of belief on the
topic of climate change and the
landscape of that Spectrum has probably
changed over several decades on one
extreme there's a belief that climate
change is a hoax it's not human-caused
to pile on top of that there's a belief
that institutions scientific political
the media are corrupt and are kind of uh
constructing this fabrication that's one
extreme and then the other extreme
there's a a level of alarmism
about the catastrophic impacts of
climate change that lead to the
extinction of human civilization so not
just economic costs hardship suffering
but literally the destruction of the
human species in the short term okay so
that's the Spectrum and I would love to
find the center
and my senses and the reason I wanted to
talk to the two of you aside from the
humility with which you approach this
topic is I feel like you're close to the
center and are on different sides of
that Center if it's possible to define
the center like there is a political
Center for Center left and center right
of course it's very difficult to Define
but can you help me Define what the
extremes are again as they have changed
over the years what they are today and
where's the center oh boy uh well in a
way on this issue I think there is no
Center except in this if you're looking
on social media or if you're looking on
TV
there are people who are trying to
fabricate the idea there's a single
question
and that's the first mistake
we are developing a new relationship
with the climate system
and we're rethinking our Energy Systems
and those are very
disconnected in so many ways that
connect around climate change but the
first way to me to overcome this idea of
there is this polarized Universe around
this issue is to step back and say well
what is this actually and when you do
you realize it's kind of an
uncomfortable collision between old
energy norms and growing awareness of
how the how the planet works that you
know if you keep adding gases that are
invisible it's the bubbles and beer if
you keep adding that to the atmosphere
because it accumulates that will change
everything is changing everything for
thousands of years it's already
happening what do you mean by bubbles
and beer CO2 carbon dioxide the main
greenhouse gas why beer because I like
beer salsa and Coca-Cola we were talking
about Cola before uh and it's so it's
innocuous we grew up with this idea is
CO2 unless you're trapped in a room
suffocating
is innocuous gas it it's plant food it's
beer bubbles and the idea we can swiftly
transition to a world where that gas is
a pollutant regulated Tamp down from the
top
is is Fantastical you know having looked
at this for 35 years I brought along one
of my tokens
this is my 1988 cover story on global
warming
the greenhouse effect yeah 1988. Jim
Hansen the famous American climate
scientist that really he stimulated this
article uh by doing this uh dramatic
testimony in the senate committee that
summer in may actually spring late
spring it was a hot day and got
headlines and this was the result but
it's complicated look what we were
selling on the back cover
where you season when you get to back
cigarettes different tobacco yeah yeah
you know looking back at my own career
on the climate question is no longer a
belief fight over is global warming real
or not you say well what kind of energy
future do you want that's a very
different question than
stop global warming and
um when you look at climate actually I
had this Learning Journey on my
reporting
where I started out with this as the
definition of the problem
you know the 70s and 80s pollution was
changing things that were making things
bad so really focusing on the Greenhouse
Effect and the pollution but what I
missed the big thing that I missed of
the first 15 years of my reporting from
1988 through about 2007.
when I was the Puritas at the New York
Times uh
in the middle there
um was that we're building vulnerability
to climate hazards at the same time so
climate is changing but we're changing
it too and we where we where we are here
in Austin Texas is a great example flash
flood alley named in the 1920s west of
here everyone forgot about flash floods
built these huge developments you know
along these river basins then one side
start saying global warming global
warming and the other side is not
recognizing that we've built willfully
uh greedily
uh the vulnerability in places of utter
hazards same things played out in
Pakistan and in Fort Myers Florida
if you and you start to understand that
we're creating a landscape of risk
as climate is changing then that it
feels oh my God that's more complex
right but it also gives you more action
points it's like okay well we know how
to design better we know that today's
coasts won't be tomorrow's coasts
work with that and then let's chart an
energy future at the same time
so the story became so different it
didn't become like
you know a story you could package into
a magazine article or the like and it
just led me to a whole different way of
even my journalism changed over time
so I don't fight the belief disbelief
fight anymore I think it's actually
kind of a waste I don't it's a good way
to start the discussion because that's
where we're at
but this isn't about to me going forward
from where we're at isn't about
tipping that balance back toward the
center so much as finding opportunities
to just do something about this stuff
what do you think Bjorn do you agree
that it's multiple questions in one in
one big question do you think it's
possible to define the center where
where is the center I think it's
wonderful to hear Andy sort of
unconstruct the whole conversation and
say we should be worried about different
things and I think that's exactly or we
should be worried about things in a
different way that makes it much more uh
useful
I think that's exactly the right way to
to think about it on the other hand that
was also where you kind of ended we are
stuck in a place where this very much is
the conversation right now uh and and so
I think in in one sense
um certainly the people who used to say
oh this is not happening they're very
very small and diminishing crowd and
certainly not right
um but on the other hand I I think to an
ex
increasing extent we've gotten into a
world where a lot of people really think
this is the you know the end of times uh
if if you so the OCD did a new survey of
all oecd countries and it's shocking so
it shows that 60 of all people in the
ocds of the rich World believes that
global warming will likely or very
likely lead to the extinction of mankind
and and and that's that's scary in a
very very clear way because look if this
really is true if if global warming is
this meter hurtling towards Earth
and you know we're going to be destroyed
in 12 years or whatever the number is uh
uh uh uh today then clearly we should
care about nothing else we should just
be focusing on making sure that that
asteroid get you know we should send up
Bruce Willis and get get this done with
but that's not the way it is this is not
actually what the U.N climate panel
tells us or anything else so I think uh
it's not so much about arcing against
the people who are saying it's a it's a
hoax that's not really where I am I
don't think that's where Andy are really
where the conversation is but it is a
question of sort of pulling people back
from this end of the world conversation
because it really skews our way that we
think about problems also you know if
you really think this is the end of time
and you know you only have 12 years
nothing that can only work in 13 years
can be considered and the reality of
most of what we're talking about in
climate and certainly all vulnerability
certainly our Energy System is going to
be half to a full century and so when
you talk to people in and say well but
we're gonna you know we're really gonna
go a lot more renewable in the next half
century they look at you and like but
that's what 38 years too late uh and I
get that but so so I think in in your
question what I'm trying to do and I
would imagine that's true for you as
well is to try to pull people away from
this precipice and this end of the world
and then open it up and I think Andy did
that really well by saying look there's
so many different sub-conversations and
we need to have all of them and we need
to be respectful of of some of these are
right in the in the sort of standard
media kind of way but some of them are
very very wrong and actually means that
we end up doing much less good both on
climate but also on all the other
problems the world faces oh yeah and it
just empowers people too those who
believe this then just sit back even in
Adam McKay's movie The don't look up
movie there was that sort of niallist
crowd for those who've seen it who just
say you know [ __ ] this or uh and and a
lot of people have of that approach when
something's too big yeah
and
it just paralyzes you as opposed to
giving you these action points and the
other thing is I hate I hate it when
economists are right about stuff like
the I I I I uh
no no they're these phrases like I never
knew the words path dependency until
probably 10 years ago in my reporting it
basically says you're in a system
the things around you how we pass laws
the Brokenness of the Senate you know
that those are we don't have a climate
crisis in America we have a decision
crisis as it comes to how the government
works or doesn't work so but those big
features of our landscape are
it's path dependency when you when you
screw in a light bulb even if it's an
LED light bulb it's going into a hundred
and thirteen hundred twenty year old
fixture
because and actually that fixture is
almost designed if you look at like 19th
century gas fixtures they had to screw
in the thing so we're like on this long
path dependencies when it comes to
energy and stuff like that that you
don't just magically transition a car
Fleet a car built today will last 40
Years it'll end up in Mexico sold on a
used car et cetera et cetera and
so this there is no quick no fix even if
if we're true that where things are
coming to an end in 13 years or 12 years
or eight years so most people don't
believe that climate change is a hoax so
they believe that there is an increase
there's a global warming of a few
degrees in The Next Century and then
maybe debate about what the number of
the degrees is
and do most people believe that it's
human caused at this time in in the in
this history of discussion or climate
change so is that the center still like
is there still the debate on this Yale
University the climate communication
group there for like 13 years has done
this six Americas study where they've
charted pretty carefully and ways that I
really find useful
what people believe and we could talk
about the word belief in the context of
science too but and they've identified
kind of six kinds of us there's from
dismissive to alarmed and with lots of
bubbles in between I think some of those
bubbles in between are mostly disengaged
people who don't really deal with the
issue and they've shown adrift for sure
there's much more majority now at the
alarmed or or engaged uh bubbles then
it's just the dismissive bubble does a
durable like with vaccination and all
lots of other issues there's a durable
never anything
belief group but on on the reality that
humans are contributing to climate
change most Americans when you're asked
ask them and it also depends on how you
write your survey you know I think I
think there's a component globally I
mean when you when you ask around I mean
and and this is you know if you hear the
story from the media of 20 years of
course that's what you'll believe and it
also happens to be true all right that
is what the sign I I think you know it's
perhaps worth saying and it's a little
depressing that you always have to say
but I think it's worth saying that I
think we both really do accept you know
the climate panel uh science and you
know there's absolutely global warming
it is an issue uh and it's probably just
worthwhile to get it out of the world
it's an issue and it's caused by humans
it's caused by humans yeah okay but
vulnerability the losses
that are driven by climate-related
events still predominantly are caused by
humans but on the ground it's where we
build stuff where we settle Pakistan
in 1968 I just looked these data up
there were 40 million people in Pakistan
today there are 225 million and a big
chunk of them are still rural they live
in the floodplain of the amazing Indus
River which comes down from the
Himalayas extraordinary 5000 year
history of Agriculture there but when
you put 200 million people
In Harm's Way and this doesn't say
anything about the bigger questions
about oh shame on Pakistan for having
more people it just says the reality is
the losses that we see in the news
are and and the science finds this even
though there's a new weather attribution
group it's a WX risk on Twitter
this does pretty good work on
how much of what just happened was some
tweak in the storm from global warming
from CO2 changing weather
but and the media glom on to that as I
did you know in the 80s 90s 2000s
but the reports also have a section on
by the way the vulnerability that was
built in this region was a was a big
driver of of loss so discriminating
between loss
change in
what's happening on the ground and
change in the climate system
is never solely about CO2 in fact
Lawrence Bauer
b-o-u-w-e-r um
has for I first wrote on his work in
2010 in the New York Times And basically
in 2010 there was no sign in the data of
climate change driving disasters
like climate change is up here disasters
are on the ground they depend on how
many people are in the way how much
stuff you built in the way and so far
we've done so much of that so fast in
the 20th century particularly
that it completely dominates it makes it
hard impossible to discriminate how much
of that disaster
was from the change in
weather from global warming so a
function of
uh greenhouse gases
to human suffering is is unclear that's
and that's very much in our control
theoretically right the the point I
think is is exactly right that you know
if you look at uh the hurricane em that
went through Florida you have a
situation where Florida went from what
600 000 houses in uh 1940 to 17 million
houses yeah sorry 10 million houses so
uh so 17 times more over uh what a
period of 80 years of course you're
gonna have one yeah yeah you're gonna
have lots more damage and many of these
houses now been built on you know places
where you probably shouldn't be building
and and so I think uh a lot of
scientists are very focused on saying
can we measure whether global warming
had an impact which is an interesting
science question I think it's it's very
implausible that eventually we won't be
able to say it has an impact but the
real question it seems to me is if we
actually want to make sure that people
are less harmed in the future
what are the levers that we can control
and it turns out that the CO2 lever uh
doing something about climate is an
incredibly difficult and slightly
inefficient way of trying to help these
people in the future whereas of course
zoning making sure that you have better
housing
rules what is it uh regulations uh that
that you maybe you know don't have
people building in the flash flood
lately what was it called flash flood
alley Alleyway yeah it's it's just
simple stuff and and because we're so
focused on this one issue we sort of it
it almost feels uh sacrilegious to to
talk about these other things that are
much more in our power and that we can
do something about much quicker and that
would help a lot more people so I I
think this is uh this is going to be a
large part of the whole conversation you
know yes climate is a problem but it's
not the only problem and there are many
other things where we can actually have
a much much bigger impact at much lower
cost maybe we should also remember those